but you went and watch Trayvon play yeah
um the night before our game um you know
how how dope was that is it is it too
early to overreact about the C how good
the Cowboys are 40 to Zero versus the
Giants I grew up a Cowboys fan we all
grew up like this is my team um I try
not to put the carriage before the horse
but I'm always having high hopes for the
Cowboys deep down inside like as you can
see me my other little brother like we
be pulling for Trey harder than we pull
anybody cuz you were we were a fan of
the team before he got there and then
you got a family member on there I don't
know it just takes it it takes it
another step so for me I have a lot of
appreciate and then when I get to see my
brother I don't know it's like I wish
everybody could enjoy or experience
having a family member you know what I'm
saying not only did you reach a
profession but better yet your younger
sibling did you know what I'm saying and
he had signed a contract as well that
was something that we were super
ecstatic for uh proud of him but then
going into that season I'm like all
right now like show me what you got you
know what I'm saying you worth some
money now and I I just poke a little fun
at him so it's definitely something to
uh I would just love I love doing he
actually came to the game came to our
game the next day I saw him there you
came to his game and he he came to our
game it was dope man you recently told
uh Pat McAfee that you would be a top
five Corner in the league yeah what
makes you say that cuz I watched my
little brother do it and I'm was like is
my brother play receiver his whole his
whole life know I'm saying he went to
Alabama he played Corner the last two
years then came in the league and show
me that it's all about having ball
skills obviously having feet and being
able to move but being an athlete if
you're a true athlete you know what I'm
saying you could played any I could have
played Safety I could have played any of
those positions I feel like if you can
run break and you got some Competitive
Edge I feel like I feel like I got a
chance and I feel like I got a knack for
the ball I talked to my little brother
had like a couple picks his first game
first year and I was like if you could
if you just caught a half of the ones
you dropped you would have had a better
year he end up grabbing 12 picks and I
was like oh yeah it's easy I probably I
need I need to get involved if you if
you a top five Corner who would be the
other
four um this a great question I say my
brother you know what I'm saying
probably be a little higher than
me um Darius
Slay pass her Tain xaven
Howard I'm trying to figure out if I'm
forgetting any names hate forgetting
guys cuz uh Jer Alexander also in and a
healthy Marshon lore for sure